the last day of next is here and it's
all about the community community day
features sessions interactive
experiences and demos for technical
practitioners like yourself while the
live broadcast will highlight some of my
favorite sessions you can find all other
community day sessions available on
demand at g dot co cloud slash next keep
in mind that you can filter on the
catalog page by learning level like
introductory intermediate and advanced
track like ai and ml app dev databases
or infrastructure job role like student
architect sre networking professional or
security professional
now my recommendations for the channel
one broadcast include a session with urs
our vp of infrastructure who will talk
through new developer-focused
announcements
don't miss this session called unleash
the innovators
then we're going to hop into a
spectacular dei session with one of the
founders of the internet a conversation
with ben cerf and jim hogan on
disability in tech
next go ahead and meet the women
techmakers team
and then join the learning and
certification q a with our experts and
check out making infrastructure
invisible for application developers
where you can discover how storage can
take care of failover and disaster
recovery with automated data replication
and how networking can remove the
complexity of traffic management as
traffic grows building better
partnerships with open source
communities will be a session with the
teams who contributed to open source
projects this past year like tensorflow
kubernetes and apache beam and they even
helped with coven 19 response efforts i
also want to highlight designing and
building serverless solutions which will
feature my teammates developer advocates
for a group discussion on cloud run
cloud functions and app engine so you
are going to learn what workloads are
best suited for serverless and some tips
and tricks channel 2 of the broadcast
will cover sessions on ml and google
developer community gatherings for both
north america and aipac and channel 3 is
all about hands-on labs for gke
autopilot etl processing with data flow
vertex ai and security so i hope you
enjoy our final day three of next and
remember connect on social with the
hashtag google cloud next and reach out
to me at steph r underscore wong